en el vídeo pasado empezamos a hablar un
poco acerca del análisis de la varianza
y calculamos lo que a la suma total de
cuadrados la suma total de cuadrados la
calculamos con estos 9 datos los cuales
están esparcidos en estos tres grupos
sin embargo hablábamos de un caso más
general donde podíamos tener n grupos y
cada uno de esos m grupos con n datos en
este vídeo quiero comparar la suma total
de cuadrados que calculamos en el vídeo
anterior con la suma total de cuadrados
de cada uno de los grupos y también la
quiero comparar con la suma total de
cuadrados entre cada uno de los grupos
pues empecemos una vez lo primero que
voy a calcular es la suma de cuadrados
dentro de cada uno de los grupos la suma
de cuadrados dentro de cada uno de los
grupos con color azul la voy a llamar la
sc de d porque está dentro de cada uno
de los grupos y en esta ocasión en lugar
de fijarme en la gran media es decir en
el promedio total
voy a sacar la suma de cuadrados
fijándome en el promedio de cada uno de
los grupos esto también lo podríamos ver
como la variación de cada uno de mis
datos con
a la tendencia central de su respectivo
grupo es decir al promedio oa la media
de su respectivo grupo entonces vamos a
tratar de calcularlo lo que hay que
hacer es primero hacer la diferencia
entre cada uno de los datos y muy
promedio de mi grupo y elevado al
cuadrado y ya con esto calcular la suma
de todos ellos por lo tanto voy a tener
tres menos dos elevado al cuadrado más
dos menos dos elevado al cuadrado más
uno menos dos elevado al cuadrado estoy
tomando cada uno de los datos de mi
primer grupo y le estoy restando mi
promedio de mi grupo y elevándolo al
cuadrado muy bien a esto hay que sumarle
qué va a pasar con el segundo grupo pues
es 5 menos 4 al cuadrado recuerden que 4
es el promedio más 44 no esperen es 3 -
cuatro más 3 - 4 elevado al cuadrado más
4 menos 4 elevado al cuadrado y ahí va a
ir un paso adelante muy bien ahora vamos
a ver hacerlo en propio con el tercer
grupo me queda más 5 menos 6 recuerden
que aquí el promedio va a ser 6 por lo
tanto voy a tomarme el primer dato
restándole el promedio 5 menos 6 elevado
cuadrado menos 6 elevado al cuadrado más
6 menos 6 elevado al cuadrado más 7
menos 6 todo esto elevado al cuadrado y
esto que va a ser igual bueno tenemos
primero 3 - 2 al cuadrado que es 12
menos 2 al cuadrado que es cero y uno
menos 2 al cuadrado que es 1 y uno más
unos dos más y me queda 5 menos 4 al
cuadrado que es 13 menos cuatro al
cuadrado que es 1 y 4 menos 4 al
cuadrado que es 0 y uno más uno me va a
dar otra vez dos y el tercer renglón voy
a tener lo mismo 10 más uno y otra vez
me datos por lo tanto la suma de
cuadrados dentro de cada uno de los
grupos va a ser igual a 2 más 2 más 2
que es 6 muy bien ahora analicemos lo
que nos está diciendo este resultado de
las 30 unidades de variación que yo
tendría de la suma total de cuadrados de
esas 30 unidades sólo 6 vienen de la
suma de cuadrados dentro de cada uno de
los grupos es decir fijémonos en la
variación total y tenemos 30 unidades
bueno de esas 30 unidades sólo 6 bien
la variación que hay dentro de cada uno
de los grupos y bueno ahora la pregunta
correcta sería cuántos grados de
libertad tenemos en este momento cuántos
grados de libertad hay cuando tenemos
suma de cuadrados dentro de cada uno de
los grupos bueno fijémonos en un grupo
primero un grupo tiene en de datos o en
este caso tenemos tres datos pero además
tenemos el promedio de cada uno de los
grupos por lo tanto podemos prescindir
de un dato en el primer grupo si nos
fijamos en el segundo grupo también
tenemos la media de ese grupo por lo
tanto podemos prescindir también de otro
dato y en el tercer grupo también
podemos prescindir de otro dato es decir
si lo vemos en un caso general yo tengo
en mi grupos tiene datos pero por cada
grupo por cada uno de los grupos
yo puedo prescindir de uno de mis datos
es decir tengo n menos 1 datos
y a esos nm unos datos hay que
multiplicarlos por la cantidad de grupos
que yo tengo es decir n menos uno por m
va a ser la cantidad de grados de
libertad que yo voy a tener en el -1
porque de cada uno de los grupos podemos
dejar un dato afuera y m porque son m
grupos por lo tanto en un caso general
cuando yo tengo la suma de cuadrados
dentro de cada uno de mis grupos los
grados de libertad van a ser m por n
menos 1 y en este caso particular que
tenemos tres grupos y tres datos en cada
uno de los grupos voy a tener tres que
multiplica a dos es decir seis grados de
libertad muy bien y ya con esto acabamos
todo el análisis que puedo hacer al
respecto o sobre la suma de cuadrados
dentro de cada uno de los grupos ahora
bien lo que quiero analizar a
continuación es qué pasa con la suma de
cuadrados pero esta vez me voy a aplicar
entre cada uno de mis grupos es decir me
voy a fijar en la variación que existe
entre cada uno de mis grupos voy a
comparar un grupo con otro para ver qué
variación existe entre ellos
y bueno como este pizarrón está muy
colorido me voy a agarrar otro color
para ponerlo para ponerle el nombre
entonces va a ser la suma de cuadrados
entre cada uno de los grupos por lo
tanto lo voy a llamar s c en suma de
cuadrados entre cada uno de los grupos
va a ser de entre muy bien y esto que va
a ser igual ahora lo que quiero hacer es
el análisis de la variación que va a ver
fijándonos en la media central a
comparación de cada una de las medias de
mis grupos por lo tanto la suma de
cuadrados entre cada uno de los grupos
va a tener que ser igual a fijarnos en
la diferencia que se encuentra entre la
media de cada uno de mis grupos y la
gran media o la media de las medias es
decir si nos fijamos en cualquiera de
los datos del primer grupo
vamos a observar que todos tienen como
media a 2 es decir la media de ese grupo
es 2 y si nos fijamos en la diferencia
entre esta media y la gran media o la
media de las medias me va a quedar
la diferencia entre 2 - 4 elevada al
cuadrado pero ojo dese cuenta que esos
para cada uno de los datos del primer
grupo porque todos todos los datos del
primer grupo tienen como media 2 por lo
tanto voy a obtener 2 menos 4 elevado al
cuadrado más 2 menos 4 elevado al
cuadrado es decir teníamos 3 teníamos 3
datos y cada uno de los datos sus medias
2 la media del grupo y después
calculamos la diferencia con la gran
media y lo elevamos al cuadrado muy bien
entonces tengo 3 por 2 menos 4 al
cuadrado que es lo mismo que 3 por 2 al
cuadrado que es 4 y esto es igual a 12 y
bueno esta es la suma de cuadrados entre
los grupos del primer grupo sin embargo
qué pasa si mejor hacemos todo recorrido
los tres grupos para no hacerlo por
separado es decir voy a juntar todo lo
que teníamos el primer grupo yo no me
voy a fijar en el segundo grupo y voy a
calcular también la suma de cuadrados
entre los grupos comparando la media del
segundo grupo con respecto a la gran
media y la media del segundo grupo era 4
de 5 3 y 4 su mediana 4 y si hacemos la
diferencia con la gran media que es 4
voy a obtener 0 y elevado al cuadrado me
va a dar 0 bueno de todas maneras le voy
a poner para que se haga de una manera
formal y no olvidemos de dónde sale cada
cosa es 4 menos 4 elevado al cuadrado
más 4 menos 4 elevado al cuadrado y si
nos fijamos en el tercer dato del
segundo grupo pues también tiene como
media 4 y le restamos 4 que es la gran
media elevado al cuadrado y bueno vamos
a hacer lo propio con el tercer grupo lo
primero que hay que fijarnos es en su
media su media 6 menos 4 elevado al
cuadrado recuerden esto es para el
primer dato del tercer grupo y para el
segundo dato es 6 menos 4 elevado al
cuadrado y después 6 menos 4 elevado al
cuadrado y muy bien si simplificamos la
suma de cuadrados entre los grupos y
ahora si den se cuenta que es la suma
total de cuadrados entre los grupos
porque ya me fijé en los tres grupos que
voy a obtener pero antes de hacer esta
larga operación fijémonos en los grados
de libertad de este caso los grados de
libertad es que tenemos una gran media
que es igual a 4
y si yo tengo una gran media y además
tengo una y dos medias más yo puedo
prescindir de la tercera media es decir
veámoslo en el caso general si yo tengo
m medias y además tengo la gran media
entonces puedo prescindir de una de
ellas por lo tanto mis grados de
libertad van a ser m
1 idem se cuenta que si yo tengo la gran
media y tengo m
un medias de una manera muy sencilla
puedo sacar la media que me falta por lo
tanto en este caso tengo m menos un
grados de libertad y bueno si nos vamos
al caso particular son tres grupos y
tres menos uno voy a obtener dos grados
de libertad en este ejercicio que estoy
haciendo bueno es hora de calcular toda
la suma total que hay entre los grupos y
para eso hay que hacer toda esta
operación larga que tenemos acá arriba
entonces que voy a obtener 2 menos 4 es
menos 2 elevado al cuadrado me da 4
positivo pero son 3 veces lo mismo
entonces es 3 por 4 ahora en el segundo
renglón tengo 4 menos 4 que es 0 elevado
al cuadrado que es 0 y 3 veces lo mismo
3 x 0 en el tercer renglón tengo 6 menos
4 que es 2 elevado al cuadrado que es 4
y 3 veces lo mismo es 3 por 4 muy bien y
tres por cuatro es 12 3 por 0 0 y 3 por
4 12 entonces 12 + 0 + 12 es 24 entonces
ya tengo la suma total de cuadrados que
hay entre los grupos o dicho de otra
manera la variación que hay entre los
grupos fijándonos en la media de cada
uno de los grupos y la media total es 24
bueno ahora vamos a unir todo lo que
tenemos si nosotros calculamos la suma
total de cuadrados es decir la variación
total entre estos 9 datos que obtendría
30 vamos a apuntar lo la suma total de
cuadrados era igual a 30 muy bien y
después calculamos la variación que
había entre cada uno de los datos según
el grupo y la media del grupo ya eso le
llamamos la suma de cuadrados dentro de
cada uno de los grupos y obtendríamos 6
por lo tanto la suma de cuadrados dentro
de los grupos era igual a 6
que por cierto en este caso teníamos 6
grados de libertad en el caso particular
y si lo veíamos en un caso más general
tendríamos m que multiplicaba a n 1 y
bueno en la suma total de cuadrados
tendríamos m n -1 grados de libertad en
el caso general y bueno en nuestro caso
particular teníamos 8 grados de libertad
entonces en el caso particular en este
ejercicio que estamos haciendo teníamos
8 y bueno para finalizar nos fijamos en
la suma de cuadrados entre cada uno de
los grupos fijándonos en la media del
grupo y fijándonos también en la gran
media y obtendríamos 24 y también
teníamos m menos 1 en el caso general de
grados de libertad y 2 en el caso
particular o en este ejercicio de grados
de libertad que quiere decir todo esto
bueno lo que quería que vieran de este
vídeo es que si nosotros tenemos la suma
de cuadrados dentro de cada uno de los
grupos y a esto le sumamos la suma de
cuadrados total entre los grupos obtengo
la suma de cuadrados total es decir si
yo me fijo en la variación que hay entre
todos los datos con la gran media y
después me fijo en la variación que hay
entre los datos con cada una de sus
respectivas medias según el grupo y
después me fijo en la variación que hay
entre las medias de cada uno de los
grupos con la media total obtengo lo
mismo y más aún no solamente en cantidad
sino también en los grados de libertad
yo tenía al principio 8 grados de
libertad y después se dividió en 6
grados de libertad en la suma de
cuadrados dentro de cada uno de los
grupos y en dos grados de libertad en la
suma de cuadrados entre cada uno de los
grupos y bueno visto de una manera
general yo tengo mm21 de la sc más m por
n
uno de la scd y esto que es igual pues
ese menos uno
voy a distribuir la m m - m y esta m y
esta m se van y me queda m por n menos
uno que son los grados de libertad que
yo tenía en la suma total de cuadrados
cuando yo lo veía de forma general es
decir coinciden tanto en cantidad como
en grados de libertad de hecho estos dos
vídeos y todas las puertas que hemos
hecho en el vídeo pasado y en este vídeo
fue para que yo les enseñara que la suma
total de cuadrados se puede descomponer
en la suma de cuadrados que hay dentro
de cada uno de los grupos en la scd y
además en la suma de cuadrados que hay
entre cada uno de los grupos en la sc
afortunadamente parece ser que no es tan
confuso todo esto